all right so island update I'm gonna
show you a couple things that we've been
working on look at my house that dude
how's that look oh my goodness people of
the Internet retro raconteur here your
guide to family-friendly content in the
world of video games today's video is
all about the scorpion alright guys have
you been lucky enough or perhaps I
should say unlucky enough to come across
one of these little beasts yet well if
you haven't yet it may have to do with
the time of day you're playing the game
you see these things are only out at
night between 7 p.m. and 4 a.m. in the
morning they are available from May all
the way through October so until the
tarantulas return in November the
Scorpions will take the place for that
terrifying late night creature that you
always have to keep track of and in
today's video I'm going to show you how
to catch these guys if you already know
how to catch the tarantulas it is pretty
much the exact same process I'm gonna
kick you guys over to my twitch stream
now where you'll see me leave my Museum
and almost stumble right on top of one
here we go alright so island update I'm
gonna show you a couple things that
we've been working on look at my house
that dude how's that look silence
silence scorpion there is a scorpion he
has not seen me yet oh he's oh you see
me now you see me now everybody remain
calm we just wait here it is guys
foolproof way to catch them just like
with the tarantulas you just got to take
it nice and slow nice and slow take a
step and a half then wait wait for him
to calm down settle down buddy there you
go wait for him wait for him to settle
down settle settle it's all good it's
all good it's all good
don't don't and there you go just like
the tarantulas you just gotta take your
time be nice and slow oh there goes my
net course be nice and slow take it easy
and you will have yourself a very
nice wonderful amazing scorpion here
which I'll show it off right here
well if this video helped you guys
please give it a thumbs up and if you've
already caught a scorpion then make sure
you let me know down in the comments how
many have you gotten how much money have
you made off these things thanks so much
for watching and I'll talk to you again
soon